et on a un coup de coeur d'isabelle
morini bosc et ça c'est un peu plus
sérieux puisque wii est a priori c'est
le genre de coup de gueule qui moi me
plaisent pas et celui ci m'a beaucoup
plu en revanche thierry ardisson
recevait samedi dans l'oeuf la vie
flamand pour son livre la consolation
elle raconte salut les terriens violée à
l'âge de 13 ans par un célèbre
photographe et en la recevant sur son
plateau il ya n'augmente télévision très
forte parce que il a dénoncé l' homme
qui la violait le nom a été bipé est il
là il l'insultait l'intérieur moi je
suis pas pour l'insultent à l'antenne
mais je reconnais que c'est un moment de
télévision très fort et qui a fait
beaucoup parler et comme en plus
évidemment on peut pas soutient
évidemment
donc c'était très fort on va on va
regarder regardez ce coup pas pourquoi
vous donnait pas son nom je ne peux pas
donner son nom parce que j'ai
aujourd'hui 42 ans et que j'avais selon
la loi française jusqu'à l'âge de 38 ans
pour pouvoir leur tournée contre mon
bureau est ce que je peux donner son nom
c'est à vous de voir tiens il a
aujourd'hui 83 ans je suis passé relaté
les mettez un bel en recul et connard
sahnouni zardi son élan mais ça c'est
fort quand même ce qu'a fait thierry
benjamin moi je ne peux que soutenir ces
flavie évidemment sur et je trouve que
les mots qu'il a employés
c'est le minimum pour ce genre de
personne ainsi nettement donc voilà bah
très bien que c'était un beau coup de l
organe à qui on dit c'est elle qui
aurait que red bull qui aurait de le
dire mais une femme-enfant pas les mêmes
mots qu'un homme ait fait ensuite les
gens dit est-ce qu'il fallait bipper ou
pas le nom à votre avis est il fallait
débuter ou pas le nom à la loi oblige
bien sûr et juridique
le photographe en question a décidé
d'attaquer après les propos ont été
tenus à gauche à droite puisque son nom
est sorti et donc je pense que la
responsabilité de la chaîne est purement
juridique pour ne pas avoir de procès
ils sont obligés de bip et le juridique
et on peut ne pas on ne peut pas le
prononcer ces infirmiers non la chaîne
aura sans preuve sans rien ne peut pas
balancer un prénom comme ça quand même
elle le sait quand même ballot ou et non
mais c'est pas elle qui a décidé de le
balancer
oui c'est thierry a lu le livre voilà
c'est par là alors que vu sa réaction il
avait l'air d'accord avec le no merci
obama je me pose la question pourquoi
elle annonce itar en fait c'était juste
ça on va pas rentrer dans les débats là
dessus ça c'est le sas et flavie qui l'a
décidé